I'm a female student in stem and I feel
bombarded by all the feminist groups
trying to infantilize me.
How do I prevent them from
turning me into an adult child?
You know,
one of the things that's really useful
to do in university is to pick your peer
group.
When I went to university,
like I made new friends in university
and that was really useful.
So I had my personal friends and they
were people who were trying to aim at
something better than what they had,
something better than what they had left.
And that was a real relief to me.
I wrote about that in my new book too.
Um,
called make friends with people
who want the best for you.
That's rule three.
Um,
but I also realized that
when you went to university,
you picked your peers and in the stem
fields what you should do is pick some
great scientists and those could be
people that you just read books about.
Pick some great scientists,
man or some great engineers.
There's some great mathematicians,
cause I don't know where
you are in the stem fields.
Pick some,
pick a hero or two or three and then
make those of your peers right and don't
pay any attention to all the noise
and Ruckus that you hear around you.
It's all nonsense anyways.
Partly what should happen when you go
to university is that you should be
introduced to great people and those
can be great people of the past.
They,
their spirits still live on in their work,
in their books,
and you can pick them as peers and
just ignore all that idiot political
nonsense.
Well,
you straighten yourself out and
learn to be great at what you do.
Develop a philosophy of greatness and
that will keep the social justice warriors
at bay.